Following on from that,
we have our functions for
on connection suspended and
on connection failed.
For now, in these, I'm just going to
log that the event has happened.
And you can see this here,
log.I, log tag.
Google API connection's
has been suspended.
And similar here,
Google API connection has failed.
Now we're almost done.
And we are almost ready to get
location updates from our phone.
Now there is one more thing
that needs to be implemented,
and that's the on location
changed call back.
Now I've created a simple skeleton for
it here.
Here you can see what I am doing is the
on location call back gets a location,
that I call location
with a lower case l.
And I'm just going to log
the location.toString and
I'm going to set tax
location.tostring on that as well.
So we can see the full location details.
So let's run this code and
see what actually happens.
Here we can see what has happened
after I've run the code, and
it's not the friendliest in the world,
does it?
But we can see that
it's basically working.
We can see our latitude,
and our longitude, and
acceleration and
altitude and even bearing.
So all this is just because we
converted the location to string.
But let's pull out,
say for example the latitude, and get
the latitude information and put it in.
And you can actually see
that it updated there and
it just updated again, because of slight
movements and me moving the phone.
So let's update this and
see what happens.
Now if you'll recall, I just had set
the txt output to be location.tostring.
But let's make this something
a little bit more interesting.
For example, let's pull out the latitude
from this and we'll work with that.
And the easiest way to do this will
be I'll just paste the code in.
And we can see here that what we're
going to do is we're going to set
the text to be location.getLatitude.
Now this returns a double, so
of course we have to pass that
to Double.toString in order to
convert that double to a string.
So now,
just the latitude from the location
object will be written to the text view.
So let's run that and take a look.
So now here, we can see the same
application is running.
But I've just gotten the latitude
of my current location, and
I've written it into the text label.
That's a lot friendlier.
And we could use that for example to
have a tax label for latitude, another
one for longitude, another one for
altitude, etcetera, etcetera, etcetera.
So very straight forward and
congratulations you've just gotten
your first location updates.